>> I'M SO GLAD WE'RE DOING THIS.
MY FAVORITE RESTAURANT WITH MY
FAVORITE PEOPLE.
>> 100%.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
THIS IS SO FUN.
DINNER IS ON US.
>> WOW.
BUT YOU KNOW YOU CAN TAKE YOUR
MASK OFF AT THE TABLE.
>> I'M SORRY.
I DON'T KNOW I'M WEARING IT HALF
THE TIME.
>> WELL, I HEARD THE CDC IS
GOING TO LIFT ALL MASK MANDATES
SO --
>> THAT'S SO WEIRD.
IT'S LIKE COVID'S NOT OVER, BUT
WE'RE ALL JUST GONNA STOP?
I DON'T KNOW HOW I FEEL ABOUT
THAT.
>> YEAH.
>> OH, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT REMINDS ME OF AN ARTICLE I
READ.
>> OH, HONEY, NO ONE WANTS TO
HEAR ABOUT THAT.
>> WELL, IT WAS IN BLOOMBERG AND
I THOUGHT IT WAS INTERESTING.
>> WHAT, UH -- WHAT ARTICLE?
>> WELL --
>> HONEY.
>> SO --
IT WAS JUST SAYING HOW MASK
MANDATES HAD, I DON'T KNOW,
LITTLE TO NO EFFECT ON COVID.
♪♪
>> I'M SORRY.
IT'S NOT LIKE I'M ANTI-MASK OR
ANYTHING.
I JUST WONDER IF SOMETIMES ANY
OF THE THINGS WE DID ACTUALLY
HELPED.
>> GINA!
>> NO, NO, NO.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THIS
INCREDIBLY COMPLICATED AND
EMOTIONAL TOPIC.
>> I WILL START BECAUSE, FOR
INSTANCE, WHILE I'M PERSONALLY
SO
RELIEVED THAT I'M VACCINATED --
>> CAREFUL.
>> -- I JUST, YOU KNOW, I
SOMETIMES WONDER IF OTHER PEOPLE
WHO ARE HESITANT --
>> CAREFUL.
>> -- MIGHT NOT HAVE, LIKE, A
VALID --
>> WHAT.
>> NOT -- NOT VALID, BUT -- BUT
AN UNDERSTANDABLE --
>> NOT TONIGHT.
>> HELP ME.
>> I THINK WHAT SHE MEANS IS
THAT SOMETIMES, WE CAN ALL BE A
LITTLE OVERZEALOUS WHEN WE
CONDEMN --
>> OH, NO.
>> I JUST THINK, IF PEOPLE ARE
ACTUALLY LOSING THEIR JOBS --
>> OH, NO.
>> CAREFUL, GIRL.
>> LOOK.
VACCINES SAVE LIVES, FACT.
OKAY?
THEY STOP THE HOSPITALS FROM
BEING OVERRUN, FACT.
>> WHERE ARE YOU UP TO?
>> BUT DID I HAVE TO DUMP MY
OLDEST FRIEND JUST BECAUSE HE
DIDN'T GET --
>> OH, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO,
NO, NO, NO.
>> -- A BOOSTER?
[ SCREECH ]
♪♪
[ THUNDERCLAP ]
>> GUYS, GUYS, COME ON.
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE FUN.
ISN'T THERE SOMETHING HAPPY WE
CAN TALK ABOUT?
>> NO!
NO.
WE STARTED THIS, AND
WE NEED TO FINISH IT.
DAVID, GO.
MAKE SENSE OF THIS.
>> OH, OKAY.
WELL, I -- I THINK THE BIGGEST
MISTAKE THE ADMINISTRATION MADE
WAS NOT PROVIDING MORE TESTING.
>> BUT THE U.K. HAD TONS OF
TESTING AND EVEN MORE COVID.
>> DUH.
>> AT LEAST BIDEN'S FINALLY SENT
OUT ALL THE TESTS OVER
CHRISTMAS.
>> YOU MEAN THE TWO TESTS FOR A
FAMILY OF EIGHT THAT FROZE IN
THE MAIL?
>> WELL, AT LEAST WE HAVE THE
CDC.
I MEAN, THEY HAVEN'T ALWAYS BEEN
PERFECT, BUT THE SCIENCE
CHANGED.
>> HM, HOW DOES SCIENCE CHANGE?
WHEN I MAKE A MISTAKE AT WORK, I
DON'T GET TO SAY, "THE SCIENCE
CHANGED."
>> AT LEAST WE HAD OUTDOOR
DINING?
>> OH.
YOU MEAN WHEN THEY BUILT
A SMALLER RESTAURANT IN THE
STREET?
HOW IS THAT OUTDOORS?
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> OKAY.
I -- I WENT TO A CHILD'S
BIRTHDAY PARTY, SO -- CAREFUL --
AND, UM, THEY DID GYMNASTICS IN
MASKS -- DON'T -- AND THEN THEY
WENT INTO ANOTHER ROOM AND THEY
TOOK OFF THEIR MASKS TO EAT
PIZZA -- THIS IS THE END OF ME.
SO DID THEY REALLY NEED THE
MASK?
>> OH, NO.
>> DID ANY OF US EVER REALLY
NEED THE MASK?
>> NO!
♪♪
[ CACKLE ]
>> I LIKE TURTLES.
[ THUNDER ]
>> MY GOD.
MY GOD.
I'M SO GLAD I
SAID THAT OUT LOUD.
>> YES, OF COURSE -- OF COURSE
WE NEEDED THE MASKS.
OF COURSE.
WE MAY NOT KNOW FOR YEARS THE
FULL EXTENT OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH, BUT WE DID OUR BEST,
AND WE'RE GOING TO GET THROUGH
THIS.
>> AMEN.
>> WHEN AN ANTI-VAXXER GETS IT,
I FEEL HAPPY.
>> NO, YOU DON'T.
NO, YOU DON'T.
>> WAIT.
WE DON'T HAVE TO WASH OUR HANDS
ANYMORE, DO WE?
>> HA, HA, HA, I NEVER DID.
>> WAIT.
WHERE'S MY WIFE?